,
AND CHANGING FILIBUSTER.
TAMMY?
>> THANK YOU CHAD VERY MUCH.
NOW HERE WITH MORE REACTION FORM
OF REPUBLICAN SCOTT BROWN, AND
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR LYRICAL
TRIAL.
LEO LET ME START WITH YOU,
BECAUSE I WILL AGREE THAT THIS
IS REALLY COSMETIC, SHE'S NOT
GONNA CHANGE YOUR APPROACH.
SHE'S GONNA BE -- I MEAN LOOK
SHE'S A MIDDLE-AGED WOMAN, AND
REMAIN WITH THE DEMOCRATS ALL
THIS TIME AND EVEN I GOT OUT OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
AND WE KNOW TULSI GABBARD DID
BUT I DO NOT SEE THIS AS AN
INDICATION THAT HER APPROACH IS
GOING TO CHANGE AT ALL.
I DON'T SEE HER EXACTLY BECOMING
A CONSERVATIVE DO YOU?
>> I DON'T SEE HER BEING A
CONSERVATIVE BUT I DO SEE HER
WRITE THE LAW.
SHE IS PRASANNA NEGRON ON THE
PARTY.
SHE'S GONNA GET PRIMARY AND SHE
KNOWS THAT.
SO SHE KNOWS SHE CAN NO LONGER
TOLERATE THE LEFT WING OF THE
PARTY.
SHE CANNOT TOLERATE THE LINE
COMING OUT OF WASHINGTON THAT
THERE IS NOT AN OPEN BORDER.
THE CRIME, THE INFLATION.
SHE IS TRYING TO FIND A MIDDLE
GROUND THE QUESTION HERE IS THAT
SHE HAD ENOUGH CONSERVATIVE
DEMOCRATS AND INDEPENDENTS AND
REPUBLICANS FOR REELECTION?
SHE CAN'T RAISE MONEY AS A
DEMOCRAT.
THIS IS FOR HER OWN SURVIVAL.
BUT I THINK IT IS A PLUS FOR THE
REPUBLICANS, BECAUSE THEY CAN
TAKE WHATEVER THEY CAN GET FROM
HER.
AND IS REALLY A KINEMATIC LOSS
FOR THE DEMOCRATS.
WHO WERE MADE TO MAJORITY BUT
SHE HAS NO FUTURE IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
>> AND THERE IS A GREAT WAY TO
PUT IT.
AND YOU KNOW SCOTT, WE HAVE A
WOMAN HERE, SHE'S A POLITICIAN
AND WANTS TO CONTINUE TO WORK.
AND SHE'S IN ARIZONA, MANY
DIFFERENT KINDS OF COALITIONS
THAT ONE CAN BUILD.
IS THIS PERHAPS PARTICIPANT
ANTICIPATING THE PROBLEMS THAT
DEMOCRATS AND A HALF?
AT 2024.
AND ALSO THE PRESUMPTION THAT
SHE CAN WIN A SENDER DEPENDENT
OR MAYBE THIS IS KIND OF THE
FIRST SOPS THAT INTO BECOMING A
REPUBLICAN WHAT IS YOUR FEELING
ON THIS?
>> WELL, SHE SHOULD PROBABLY
TALK TO LEASE UP IN ALASKA, I
MEAN SHE DID GO THROUGH
SOMETHING VERY SIMILAR AS SHE
VOTED 93% OF THE TIME OF THE
PARTY BUT THAT IS STILL NOT GOOD
ENOUGH.
LISTEN FOLKS, THIS IS A JFK'S
PARTY, THIS IS VERY LITTLE ROOM
THERE'S VERY LITTLE ROOM FOR ANY
DEVIATION OR BREAKING FROM THE
PARTY LINES.
AND IF IT WAS SOMEBODY WHO, WHO
WAS JUST TRYING TO DO FOR SELF
OF SURVIVAL I'D BE MORE
CONCERNED OR UPSET, BUT JOE AND
HER HAD THE BEST GUYS IN THE
STREET CREDIT TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
DECISIONS LIKE THAT BECAUSE THE
WAY THAT SHE WAS TREATED WAS
HORRIFIC.
MA FOLLOWING INTO THE BATH AND
THE COST TO HARASSMENT.
JUST BECAUSE SHE WANTED TO GET A
BETTER DEAL FOR THIS COUNTRY
AMID THE SPENDING THAT WE ARE
SEEING IS LEADING TO INFLATION
OBVIOUSLY.
THAT WE'VE NEVER SEEN IN MY
LIFETIME THAT I REMEMBER.
AND IT NEVER STOPPED.
SO I THINK THIS GIVES HER A
LITTLE BIT OF EXTRA CONTROL
WHILE THEY DON'T WANT TO TAKE
OFF TOO MUCH THEY THEY MIGHT
LOSE A COUPLE OF SUBCOMMITTEE
CHAIRS ARE COMMITTEES OR
WHATEVER, THAT IF THEY KEEP
PUSHING THE SHOW GO NEXT DOOR
AND JOE MANCHIN MAY BE NOT TOO
FAR BEHIND.
BECAUSE I ALWAYS THOUGHT THAT
JILL WAS A FRIEND AS A
REPUBLICAN.
AND HE HAS THOSE STRONG
CONSERVATIVE JFK VALUES.
AND THAT IS NO LONGER NEEDED OR
WANTED IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
DAY SADLY.
>> LEO, WE BOTH HAVE SEEN WHAT
THE LEFT'S ABOUT HER AND THE
DEMOCRATS.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW WHEN YOU
SEPARATE YOURSELF EMOTIONALLY,
AND POLITICALLY, THAT THERE IS A
CERTAIN FREEDOM TO BEING PERHAPS
MORE HONEST AND BEING MORE
YOURSELF.
THERE IS LESS FEAR ATTACH.
HOW DO YOU THINK THAT MY PLAN
FOR HER?
>> I THINK IT WILL PLAY OUT
WELL FOR HER, BECAUSE SHE IS
LIBERATED AND SHE DOES NOT HAVE
TO WORRY ABOUT THE RHETORIC FROM
THE FAR LEFT.
IT IS ANOTHER WAY ABOUT SQUAT.
YOU SAW THAT QUIT BY AOC, THEY
HATE HER AND SHE KNOWS IT.
SO NOW SHE SHE HAS A DEGREE OF
INDEPENDENCE, I'LL TELL YOU
RIGHT NOW SHE'S A POLITICAL
ANIMAL RIGHT NOW.
SHE WANTS TO STAY IN POLITICS,
AND THEY HAD A PLAYBOOK THAT
WORKS WELL WHEN HE LEFT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY SO I THINK SHE
JUST NEEDS TO TALK TO JOE
LIEBERMAN AS WELL TO FIND OUT
WHAT'S THE PLAN TO ONE AS AN
INDEPENDENT.
AS YOU NEED TO START WORKING ON
THAT PLAN RIGHT NOW IS THE
FUND-RAISING.
SHE'S NOT CAN I RAISE A NICKEL
IS A DEMOCRAT.
>> THAT'S A GREAT POINT WHEN
HE WAS STILL A DEMOCRAT HE WAS
TH